so let me begin with ukraine
a couple of things first of all what are
putin's intentions
we have individuals on radio on tv who
write columns who claim to be able to
know what putin's intentions are well i
know what his intentions are
how do i know what his intentions are
because he wrote about it
in july of last summer seven months ago
and among other things in this 5 000
word essay which has not probably been
discussed with you in many newsrooms or
by many commentators just because
they're lazy
he makes it abundantly clear
that this is about more than ukraine
to him ukraine doesn't exist it's always
been russian that the ukrainians are not
a separate people they are russians
and he talks about more than that he
talks about poland and hungary really
there should be no poland and hungary
either the balkans nah they're russian
too
he's not so much stalin while he is in
his tactics but not in terms of his
territorial gains he's more catherine
the great if you will
and this this piece that he wrote or
that somebody wrote for him that he
signed and embraced
is on the kremlin site
uh and it also goes back twelve hundred
years
twelve hundred years so much like adolf
hitler
the one in the sedate lane and other
areas because he said they're germans
there and they speak german putin has
used the same tactic in that respect
now what about america does america have
national security interests in ukraine
or in europe in nato
85 of the american people surveyed just
a few days ago and a massive survey done
by fox said yes ukraine matters to the
united states 85 percent to 14.
so those who say we have no national
security interest or interest at all in
ukraine are in a very very small
minority
how about zilinski is he all this bad
guy that he's that he's said to be with
russian propaganda and his surrogates
repeating their talking points
76 percent of the american people
approve of zielinski that's pretty good
as most politicians in america
and should we do more to help the
ukrainians maybe get them some big
fighters so they can actually
do more damage to the russian invaders
and the putin military machine
63 of the american people say yes we
should do more and a huge percentage of
republicans can be found in all those
figures
so the outliers are not the people who
say
maybe we ought to do more to help our
ukrainian friends and we're not talking
about
indiscriminate intervention we're not
talking about stupid things like sending
troops into ukraine or having our jets
shoot down russian jets over ukraine in
a no-fly zone we're talking about things
that can be done you know the way ronald
reagan brought down the soviet union the
way reagan supported the uh
uh the northern alliance and others
against the soviets in uh in afghanistan
the way we took on the soviets in angola
and in our own hemisphere and on and on
and on that these are things that can be
done and should be done
we are not the imperial power ladies and
gentlemen we are not the colonialists
some of these american firsters sound
like american lasters who seem to blame
us and they will point to some american
blunders
military blunders and i agree with them
in many respects they'll point to
afghanistan they'll point to iraq
they'll point to libya
uh they'll point to um
vietnam the point to other things
but let me tell you something that is
absolutely nothing to do with what's
going on today
nothing
whatsoever
who is
who is the aggressor it's putin
he's slaughtering innocent civilians
he's blowing up cities
one town on the black sea is 90 percent
leveled wherever putin goes this is what
he does he's destroyed syria with his
favorite genocidal maniac there he's
destroyed the chechen area um he is
destroying ukraine that's what he does
he fancies himself uh catherine the
great but when it comes to tactics he
fancies himself stalin he is a man who
has killed his way to the top he's a man
who assassinates in order to hold on to
power
he's now shuffling the decks around him
his hand-picked generals his hand put
stasi types and so forth he's removing
them and replacing his yes men
some of them are disappearing some of
them are trying to leave the country
that's what we're up against and so uh
now we get this stuff that the united
states should not escalate tensions
excuse me
yeah we are not supposed to escalate
tensions
well how are we escalating tensions by
helping an ally
an ally that's trying to defend itself
trying to save its people who are being
slaughtered unprovoked
by a madman a genocidal maniac
who believes that russia should control
two-thirds of europe
because he goes back
12 centuries and dreams up a a
bastardized idea of ancient history no i
don't think so
well he keeps threatening to use nuclear
weapons well that's amazing
he's a war criminal
he's involved in horrific atrocities
he is threatening to use nuclear weapons
now and then
and yet people in this country
mostly the putin wing
are saying how dare you talk about the
potential of taking out putin
so he's a war criminal he's committed
atrocities he's committing genocide not
the first time he threatens the us with
nuclear weapons
and he shouldn't be taken out
that's about as stupid as it gets
i'm not saying we have to take him out
but we can encourage others to do
exactly that and maybe that's what's
going on have you heard the head of his
military's been missing for for about
two weeks and nobody knows where he is
hmm i wonder if they already tried we'll
see and i hope they succeed if they do
so putin laid out a pretext for what
he's doing those who are confused some
intentionally so on what his ultimate
plans are should read what the man wrote
or at least purportedly wrote but
certainly embraces it was on the kremlin
website he tells you what he wants to do
now there's also this effort to smear
zalinski
the president of ukraine so anytime
something happens in war
it is used by the uh by the putin wing
of the republican party the democrat
party and the media and so forth they
don't tell you that putin has locked up
his main political opponent for another
nine years
on uh trumped up embezzlement charges
they don't tell you about any of that
stuff uh or that uh all the
assassinations that he's been involved
in both in his country and outside his
country including in washington dc at
some hotel no
and of course he's trying to assassinate
the president of ukraine he sends in
chechnyan uh headhunters he sends in the
wagner group which
is his favorite personal little militia
and so forth and so on
uh but they're trying to smear him and
there's a great piece in the cato
institute commentary
by kathy young who goes into this how
ukraine has been attacked and how russia
has been promoted by by the likes of the
late
professor stephen cohen in the nation
max blumenthal in salon seamus milne in
the guardian
and saurabh omari in the american
conservative which is basically a
buchananite
publication in many respects
this isn't about rhinos
and the republican war mongers
and neocons
really
neocons you know neocons is a pejorative
for democrats
jewish democrats who switched over to
reagan because they supported his
approach to the soviet union this is a
phrase that is used purposely to create
the impression about who's behind this
jewish intellectuals but then if you
raise it say hey isn't it funny every
time we speak we're accused of
anti-semitism no nobody is accusing you
of anti-semitism unless you're using
phrases that suggest you are
as for the washington war machine there
is no washington war machine
the united states military is is being
depleted of resources the men and women
in the military are not treated like
with respect as fighting men and women
they're being taught critical race
theory there was a washington war
machine
the opposite would be done wouldn't it
have there been blunders in our foreign
policy yes but there's no collusion or
conspiracy between federal contractors
the neocons and the washington war
machine
and these events in the past
have nothing to do with what putin's
doing today again you want to know what
putin's doing today read what he says
but these these attacks on zielinski the
president of ukraine who i don't know
and i've never spoken to
uh you can hear them echoed by syrian
dictator assad
in al-jamanir here he he calls him a
zionist jew who supports the nazis
communism islam nazism china russia
anyone else are not the enemies of the
west he proclaimed if they serve the
interests of the west they are friends
in other words they have zero principles
sounds like some people in our own
country the ugliest truth of them all
and not many people know this is the lie
that the west and zionism oppose nazism
he said not many people know that the
leaders of the nazis in ukraine nazi
organizations that closely collaborated
with hitler in terms of security
military and ideology were driven out of
ukraine at the end of world war ii some
of them europe and some of them to
america
this past september
some of that's true by the way about
nazism in ukraine
and some of it's true about nazism in
the united states and anti-semitism in
the united states in places like
brooklyn and the bronx you might recall
and during the black lives matter riots
including in los angeles and when hamas
was shooting missiles into israel
and uh and the activities that took
place in new york which were quite
horrific and that the number one victim
of hate crimes in this country are jews
but this is a fantastic country this
isn't a country that harbors nazis nor
is ukraine a country that harbors nazis
even though there are elements within
their society as there are many elements
within the russian society and there are
many elements in the democrat party as
far as i'm concerned if you listen to
some of the more extremists in that
party but that's not my point
my point is there's two types of
opponents to supporting ukraine really
two broad categories
number one are your typical pacifists
code pink types
who are just
wrong in many ways
moronic
you know we got a lot of things to do
here in the united states we can't be
paying attention to other countries we
have our own border to secure why would
we worry about the border with
ukraine uh excuse me we should worry
about both borders we should be securing
our border and worry about the border
with ukraine way to recent president
donald trump who understood that
and these extremists are nothing like
donald trump in fact many of them
condemned donald trump when he took out
sulaimani said it was very provocative
with the iranians why are we involved
even though sulaimani is responsible for
the death and casualties of thousands
and thousands of americans
you see the wounded warriors program you
see tunnels to towers program many of
the people that they're helping have
head injuries have lost body parts as a
result of what the iranian regime did
with suleiman running the terrorist
operations they attacked trump when he
also attacked the syrians and attacked
their airport killed several hundred
russians as i understand it who were
remaining that airport when they were
gassing their own people so donald trump
is not one of these these uh pacifist
uh isolationist types but there is a
doctrine of that sort and then there's a
different one
which really is a a putin-type
mouthpiece operation propagandist in
this country
and they are involved in the sort of
thing that assad is trashing is a linsky
they're involved in the sort of thing
that assad is in other respects too that
is defending um a putin in terms of he
needs space
he needs his space and historically they
needed space and of course they come up
with with nonsense like well ukraine
wanted to join nato so therefore
putin wanted to put an end to it ukraine
was not going to join
nato ukraine just said it wouldn't join
nato
and its cities are still being
obliterated that said the ukrainians are
fighting like heroes
they're doing everything they can to
fight the russians
the russian military machine is is vile
in the way it attacks cities and
innocent citizens
when it comes fighting man to man on the
battlefield it's not as strong as they
thought
so my view the ukrainians deserve all
the support they can get if we can
contain this war to that part of the
world that would be a good thing so it
doesn't bleed into the nato countries so
it doesn't bleed into taiwan we're
cheesing what's taking place and of
course with biden arming the iranians
with nuclear warheads this is a separate
and holy grave
issue
that needs to be more fully addressed
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else